[Music]
we're very fortunate we got a lot of
fans and followers on Twitter and
Facebook and Google+ and YouTube but I
realized not long ago there is one vital
piece missing from my social media
empire I'm talking about LinkedIn okay
now I don't really know I don't know
what LinkedIn is I really don't know it
has to do something with business right
I think right I know nothing about
business I know nothing about LinkedIn
regardless I found out that I didn't
have a presence there and I was enraged
so I went ahead and I created a LinkedIn
profile yeah there I am there I am this
is all real I created a real LinkedIn
profile there I am wearing a suit that I
bought from Steven Seagal
in the mid-80s then about two weeks ago
I became this is true I became something
called a LinkedIn influencer and in two
weeks have already amassed over 68,000
followers that's right there I am just
ahead just ahead of Josh Burson and Olaf
Swan teeth suck it guys and now I'm
gunning for a guy named Jeffrey Moore
I'm coming on Jeffrey Moore can feel my
high on the back of his neck yeah
so we're on our way to the top of
LinkedIn but I must have more followers
now I've noticed some people on LinkedIn
post pictures of themselves with a world
leader for example the founder of
Craigslist Craig Newmark posted a
profile photo of himself with President
Obama okay oh wow cool all right
well guess what Craig Newmark I've got
something better this is gonna put me on
top of this site okay I don't know why
I'm doing this hi everyone can still
hear me right I don't either I'm doing
this but there's a microphone right here
not good don't tell anyone okay
that guy has a picture of him with
President Obama right yeah yeah big
effing deal my new profile picture
features me with former presidents Bill
Clinton George Bush
and check this out we're all standing in
the palm of Pope Francis
[Applause]
top of Lincoln now you can help me to
connect with me visit team koco.com
slash linkedin this is a waste of your
time and my time let's waste America's
time together
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow I became too self-absorbed yeah it
happens